yeah welcome to this video playing fritz
car Fritz car yeah one new thing that
you see in the video now is that ICC has
changed something you get a 10-second
grace period which is nice because I
sometimes stop the video a little bit a
little bit late and I mean due to
starting of the video I sometimes lose a
couple of seconds right at the beginning
of the video and so this the second sis
these seconds I know and now won't lose
any more yeah ok so what is this this is
them McCutchen variation of the French
defence an opening that I don't know
really that well Laura yeah some people
might say that I don't know it at all
which it wouldn't be wouldn't be foul of
the truth yeah how do I play that
Queenie five maybe I really don't know I
really don't know is this the right way
to do it I think this is probably a
known position right you see threatening
of three and probably okay let's take
him the whole thing can get scary rather
quickly on the dark squares my dark
squares are huge a huge issue
some rights is six maybe yeah I mean 94
you cannot play another taking you five
so maybe he has to play move like yeah
like this to make sure things are not
getting getting lost um yeah and now
sticking on c3 probably yeah as
mentioned the dark squares but is it
that terrible it would be great if I
could get the bishop to c6e m97 Bishop
d7 Bishop c6 this kind of thing home
yeah and so i guess i have to Castle I
at some point difficult to to not do
that all together on Bishop 83
how do I get this developed gem
something like b6 special basics but c6
is hanging i also have a move like queen
d 5 which is probably not bad yeah it's
not bad but it's also not particularly
great but ah ok i was more expecting him
to take hear something like be six
should be takes Queen down ok you can
take and go to e4 am immediately but I
have Queen d4k so Knight c3 queen d 4
sir it's ok yeah Bishop e3 route 28
should be ok as well ok let's it's a bit
of a problem bishop to be seven yeah
maybe I have 94 as a possible idea like
rookie 190 form
yes still 94 right or is this blundering
stuff not really why isn't that this bed
then I don't see why okay 13 made on g2
I mean nothing's terrible is happening
you can just go to f2 here yet I
certainly do my disposition trying to
check on situation ever got to take the
c3 porn so if I'm getting see to it
would be great okay that didn't work if
you rub c84 for Roxy for brooke d for I
have Queen f5 I mean okay I always kept
mentioning the week dark squares but
well I'm pretty strong on the light
square so um yeah I have to do that hmm
yeah just securing the Queen for good
measure I mean g4 wasn't a threat but so
huh I don't really know how to to do
anything maybe Bishop d5 start with that
and go for Roxy for trying to trade
something I need to enter with the ropes
if I can get to enter with my ropes I
might maybe I can do something trying to
play for when Roxy for has a move this
kind of idea
looks for him I am and what is the idea
g4s the idea o ok ty morning 97 ok i
might play G all right
I can pledge you find myself it's not
really great g4 takes TX g5 hmmmmm 37
seconds that's the biggest issue
hmm we're looking something go again
possible I mean I already have
overlooked something to get into this in
the first place is bad because I was um
I was just winning before or clearly
better let's say check winning is a bit
is a bit much yeah 30 33 seconds so this
is a superb this is a big issue
yeah as a position you can absolutely
never lose I mean the on position let's
say nine can you just you just stay as
black and can never lose but can also
not win yeah it's repetition yeah okay I
suddenly spoiled a very good position
there but I'm definitely was rusty after
break playing even even if it's slower
than then I usually do yeah hmmm I
wonder to something right here we are
still within theoretically child charted
waters I guess yeah around here I'm
beginning to get to have the better
position but maybe yeah it is nothing
particularly special look you form yeah
probably here Queen f5 looks good but it
gets into some sort of yeah and since
some troubles on f5 hey I should have
gone to c6 yeah that looks all very
normal are you Queenie to was good okay
what did he do went here Kim Kim check
here winning but wine either should be
four no yeah already wasn't a little bit
of a panic motor for sure because of the
time we should be fourth of course very
strong just attacking this and he cannot
come upon that wins pretty much on the
spot yeah
very simple okay mash definitely should
have done that even though 30 34 seconds
would have been enough and to convert
that and here I mean I just wanted to
have the simplest possible position with
here I succeeded with that but of course
this is really just a draw okay well
thanks for watching